[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to channel
awesomes orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world
and pop culture and entertainment news
i'm heather ruse and this is your news
for monday october 2nd
obviously I'm flying solo today Ayana is
out battling the sith no seriously she's
at a lightsaber Jedi workshop so we wish
her luck on our mission this week and
hopefully we'll see you next week
also this week we had a lot of reboots
and spin-offs announced for movies
first of all appropriate to our month of
October Disney announced that
hocus-pocus is getting a reboot but
don't get too excited because it's going
to be a Disney Channel original movie
it's not getting a theatrical release
and in fact almost none of the original
creative team is coming back including
director Kenny Ortega and the original
Sanderson sisters themselves Sarah
Jessica Parker Bette Midler and Kathy
Najimy and I don't think this is voting
very well for the film first of all it's
gonna have only a TV movie budget which
means it's not really gonna live up to
the expectations of the cult classic
stature that surrounds this movie at
this point also some of the original
charm of the movie was the direction of
Kenny Ortega and the wonderful Sanderson
sisters themselves it's definitely going
to lose a lot with someone else
attempting to play these characters
there's still no release date as for
when this is going to come out on the
Disney Channel so just keep an eye out
for it Sony announced this week that
it's fast tracking a spin-off for men in
black for a May 20 19 release date we
don't have much for it except the fact
that it has a script and Will Smith and
Tommy Lee Jones will not be returning as
the main characters they haven't
completely
as hashed out whether or not there's
going to be a cameo for them but they're
definitely not going to be the main
characters rather they're going to be
focusing on the men in black
organization on a global scale which I
think could be an interesting new take
on the series but I think it also might
open the series and the movie to this
issue of a huge cast with a lot of
storylines going on that creates kind of
a mishmash of things happening at once
but we'll just have to wait and see
another reboot heading our way is of the
1980s classic sci-fi film flight of the
navigator right now Joe Henderson is
writing the script and he is the
showrunner for Lucifer currently Disney
attempted to remake this movie in about
2009 let it fell flat on its face
so now Lionsgate is taking the movie and
the rights with a so in association with
the Henson Company which i think is
great news because if you're gonna
remake this movie you should do it with
someone like the Henson Company who is
going to be using practical effects and
maybe some puppets for the aliens so I'm
actually pretty excited for this to see
what the Henson Company is going to do
with the rights to this movie speaking
of 1980s nostalgia freaks and geeks is
going to get a behind-the-scenes
documentary it's going to be premiering
on a and E in a part of Morgan
Spurlock's new docu-series culture shock
and in this series Spurlock will be
investigating what he is calling
watershed moments in pop culture history
and considering the talent that came out
of freaks and geeks despite the fact
that it was only one season I think it
definitely counts as a part of our
cultural comedy landscape at this point
lastly paramount announced that it has
bought the rights to do a live-action
American remake of the anime your name
which is the highest-grossing animated
right now was set to produce it and guys
I'm
but this news is extremely irritating to
me the original movie in and of itself I
thought was brilliant I loved it
if you haven't had a chance to check it
out it is visually beautiful the story
is interesting and great and it's coming
out on blu-ray in America on November
7th I can't tell you too much as a plot
without getting into some super spoiler
territory but basically the premise is
kind of Freaky Friday ish where there's
a boy and a girl who switch lives they
only do it every now and then it's not
like the whole movie is them
rediscovering who they are
et cetera so they do it a couple of days
at a time they start writing notes to
each other about what happened during
the day that they switch because they
can't remember what happened when they
do the switching it is a really
heartfelt story it's funny there are
points where it was sad I was like ugly
sobbing through half of the movie at
some points it is a very gripping story
and I just really don't think that an
American remake is going to bring
anything to the table there's gonna be
some cultural things that are gonna have
issues being translated and it's just
going to lose I think some of the magic
of the original so like I said do
yourself a favor and just check out the
original I'm Blu right
November 7th okay just leave it alone
Hollywood leave it alone in other movie
news Danny Elfman spilled some secrets
this week about the Justice League score
with an interview with billboard he
revealed that they are using the iconic
John Williams Superman theme which I am
super excited about I think it's really
interesting to see the DC you finally
bringing in successful pieces of other
movies into the new movies however else
Minh did say and I quote that this is
going to be used in a dark moment in a
dark way in the film when we're not
quite sure if Superman is a friend or a
foe of the Justice League so it sounds
like he's taking the melody and
twisting it a little bit from what we
know and love but again personally I'm
excited about this change to see those
iconic moments from past movies brought
into the current landscape he also said
that he created some simple themes and
motifs for newcomers flash cyborg and
Aquaman so that when or if they ever get
their own movies the composers of those
movies can build off the base for what
he has which I think completely makes
sense for a composer like this Justice
League does come out on November 17th so
it's only a month and a half away which
feels closed I feel like we've been
talking about this movie for years but
it's only a month and a half away
everyone so let me know in the comments
below if you think it's gonna be a great
movie movie or a total flop we'll just
have to wait and see in other movie news
annihilation an alien horror film
starring Natalie Portman released its
first trailer this week in the movie
Portman plays a scientist who is going
on a mission in an area that looks for
an alien maybe in some place that's had
a natural disaster and she's also
looking for her husband and so far the
trailer seems pretty interesting I never
read the book but I've heard good things
about it the trailer looked pretty good
there's a couple of really nice visual
elements that I enjoyed and I'm pretty
compelled by it so so far I'm on the
train for this one I like Natalie
Portman and I would like to see what she
does with the character and that drops
on February of 2018 in TV show news we
finally got our first look at some of
the characters from The Runaways TV show
and the series is based off the comic
book which is about a group of teenagers
who discovered that their parents are
actually supervillains so they have to
band together to stop their parents evil
plan it's a great coming-of-age story
written by one of my favorite comic book
are authors Brian cave on so if you
haven't read it I recommend that you
check it out
but the stills that we saw from the
series look great they look pretty
accurate to the TV show so even though I
did not see my telepathically linked
dinosaur in it quite yet
you'll know what I mean if you are the
comics I am still really excited to see
it and again it's going to be
exclusively on Hulu and drops on
November 21st
lastly Twitter made an announcement
earlier this week that they are
expanding their character limit from 140
to 280 and this is a huge change for the
social media platform we it's yet to be
seen whether it's going to be a good
thing or a bad thing personally as a
grammar level lover I hope to see more
punctuation some correct grammar commas
apostrophes thrown in there where they
should be however I also know that we
might just get a lot of incoherent rants
and trolls because Twitter that's what
happens sometimes on that platform I
don't have 280 characters yet I only
have 140 so let me know if you have it
yet you can tweet at me and no one let
me know in the comments but I don't have
it yet that's gonna do it for us this
week let me know in the comments below
what you guys are most excited to see
with our reboots and spin-offs
personally I think I'm most excited to
see the flight of the navigator movie
right now but again we'll just have to
wait and see you can find me on Twitter
at Heather Ruth's Instagram at a truce
or twitch twitch TV slash Heather Roose
I'm hoping sometime this weekend to do a
stream of episode 2 season 2 of the
Batman telltale series so if that's
something that you're interested in make
sure you follow me on Twitch so we'll
see you guys later
for now beam me up
[Applause]
you